any economy is a super complicated thing
so what i'm going to do in this video is
a super oversimplification but it's just
a way for thinking about things and in
particular i want to think about why
good economies tend to be associated
with a moderate level of inflation and
that'll also help inform us when we
start thinking about stagflation when we
have inflation with a bad economy so in
a good economy employment is up and
because employment is up employees have
more negotiating power there's more
people who want to hire them there's
fewer people who want their jobs and so
wages will go up and since you have more
people with jobs and those that have
jobs you're getting paid more you can
imagine that demand would also go up
there's just more more people have money
in their pockets and if demand goes up
then
companies or if you think of as
factories but it could also be services
then everything will be utilized more
and if things are utilized more then the
companies or those factories or whatever
you want to think of them they're going
to have
they're going to have more profit on top
of that if they get close to fully util
full utilization or if they see that
full utilization is down the road
they're going to want to invest more
and they could actually push off that
full utilization and still get more
profit by maybe raising prices
so this is where that moderate level of
inflation really shows up a fact if
there's more demand a factory can
produce a little bit more and it could
raise prices a little bit more so this
is where
the moderate level of inflation shows up
and there is a little bit of a negative
feedback loop if price goes up it will
it will inhibit demand a little bit and
that's why it's moderate inflation we're
not talking about some type of crazy
inflationary spiral here but the net
effect of more utilization and more
investment is going to be an increase in
supply
it's going to be an increase in supply
and once again and this is kind of econ
101.
if supply goes up price that would also
have a bit of a
inhibitory impact on
on price so let me draw a little bit of
a just so we get all the feedback loops
over here so this is negative feedback
right over there
but to complete the loop if we're
investing more we're going to build more
factories or or some more capacity to do
services or whatever else that's going
to increase employment if we have more
profit then a company feels better about
growing it feels like it has more of a
cushion and it feels more optimistic
about the future that's going to help
employment and obviously utilization
itself if we run the factory lines
longer we're going to need more people
to run on those lines so though that
also
will increase employment so this is just
a general kind of feedback loop and you
can make you know you could add a little
nuanced twist to this but this is the
general idea of why a moderate level
inflation is kind of associated with
this i would call it a pretty virtuous
cycle what we would normally see in a
good economy